there are three major benefits for you
having a business plan in place and
here's what it is number one when you
write out a business plan when you take
a piece of paper and start saying this
is what we're gonna do and then do we're
doing this first quarter we'll do this
I'm gonna focus on this this is what we
get if we do this we'll get this if I
get this I'm going to get myself this
you get clarity on what you're doing and
when you get clarity that gives you
enthusiasm because you know if we hit
this we're getting this and that's
exciting and you need enthusiasm in
business the second thing it gives you
it gives you a target here's what our
target is by the end of q1 here's what
our target is by the end of this month
here's what our target is by the end of
the year what a target gives you is
focus you then become focused about your
target and you can minimize all the
distractions and last but not least when
you are clear when you have a target and
you set deadlines that gives birth to
urgency in an organization who has high
enthusiasm an organization who is fully
focused and an organization who is
urgent to hit their deadlines to hit
their target to hit their goals that
they're clear about it is a very
difficult to compete with that
individual and to compete with that
organization